johnny greggy are you ready to get hit
with that
guys the venom two let there be carnage
trailer is finally
finally here after like a year of
people saying the trailer's coming out
in a week so it's always a week but
finally it's here
i hope we get to see some cletus cassidy
let's get to it i'm so excited i'm so
[Music]
excited
[Music]
no eugene people
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
excuse me
[Laughter]
that's very relatable it's very
relatable
[Laughter]
i am very enthralled so far
because you and i are the same
oh every decision
day the bugle
a lot of hints i miss you
so much
[Music]
i really was going to be so much better
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
dude i love the tone of this trailer
love the tone of it
[Music]
no we um a deal what's gonna happen
you're gonna stop protecting
[Laughter]
oh me dude oh look at that he's all
wrapped in the
holy [ __ ] it's real it's actually real
i love the tone of that that really dug
the tone of that they really amped up
the like that bromance the buddy
between the two of them he's miss chan
he's going to eat your head if you don't
get him some chocolate damn chocolate
get
him some chocolate come on all right you
fix the damn
chocolate i love the look of carnage
i love everything i'm seeing that woody
harrelson is doing
we both liked venom and i think we were
both surprised by like how much we
enjoyed it we by no means thought it was
like a perfect movie though like it
certainly had its problems part of
that's part of what made it so fun
though
it works despite a lot of things yeah
but i think you know andy circus is
directing this one and i feel like an
improvement
upon the handling of the pacing and the
tone granted it's just a trailer but i
really feel like for a two minute
two and a half minute trailer after all
this time i felt like it took its time
pretty well with showing us a pretty
clear-cut tone and i love just the way
this trailer is composed like you have a
lot of that fun with getting back with
eddie brock and venom and you see eddie
and he he just seems like
he's not sleeping at all he's so fed up
with kind of the behavior
and the energy and antics that the
living venom provides for him he just
looks like so defeated
yeah yeah and tired yeah it's funny it's
really funny
um but then you have this like insidious
build of like there's something evil
lurking around the corner you're just
waiting for it and then it's like you're
building up cletus cassidy in this
trailer
even from like the post-credits scene
that you got in
um in the first venom movie to hear
you're like i feel like he's
kind of i thought i was a little worried
he might be a little too over the top
yeah yeah and maybe he'll go bigger as
the movie progresses
but here i'm like now you're hitting the
right sadistic woody harrelson
note i'm really enjoying it so far
and uh i love how you have that similar
shot of how you saw in the first fender
movie when he
at least when the in the trailer like
mirroring that one
he's embracing it yeah versus like addie
who was like what's going on
cletus is also in power obviously yeah
even more mayhem and chaos to come and i
yeah this trailer gave me the sense that
they really looked at the last movie and
went what worked
and what needed to be improved upon yeah
and i appreciate that yeah they start
out with that buddy vibe between
eddie brock and venom that's argued that
is the most
uh you know qualitative thing the first
movie has to offer and then yeah
building upon that with the menace of
cletus cassidy's carnage and also too i
mean i feel like some people had
trepidations about woody harrelson's
portrayal and this got me that much more
intrigued for what he'll bring to it
because it looks like he has some of
that woody harrelson you know
drawl that he is you know famous for but
also like
there is that percolating chaotic
unpredictable menace
underneath the surface that leads me to
believe that he could also embody this
crazy
maniacal character that carnage really
is woody harrelson could be kind of
chill
of course yeah well it's called let
there be carnage and
i don't know for sure i i haven't done
much
research on this movie itself nor has
much been released
but this lady i'm wondering if this is
the character shriek
uh who is very much associated within
the carnage comics and i don't know
like exactly how this plot will unfold
but it looks like carnage will be
taken into the streets in a lot of crazy
ways like this breakout out of
ravencroft looks insane it looks like
it's about a ravencroft who's this actor
i love
that actor the guy who's playing the cop
i like baron holds not something like
barrett holds
are you crazy i'm sorry it's just like
baron
i know he's the guy from the irishman in
snatch
steven he's an amazing actor i i didn't
even i didn't even know he's in this
movie
yeah i i didn't uh but he is a fantastic
actor stephen graham
stephen graham and he always has a
script for you you redeemed yourself
they always has a great stream presence
i love that it's a daily bugle and then
with this speech
that cletus cassidy is giving here looks
like it's his death row speech
yeah certainly yeah i'm wondering
exactly
why he's having these choice of words
maybe he only got like a little bit of
the symbiote at that time or got a taste
of it beforehand
but then he gets fully infected with it
right before he's about to be executed
yeah maybe the symbiote has a plan
because it's the other thing too is like
i can totally imagine them talking in
the cell and hatching some kind of
you know escape plan or whatever so yeah
this speech that he has prepared to give
to all these people right before he
breaks out it seems like the kind of
villainous thing he would be up for and
with andy serkis who is famous for his
work on mocap the effects
look very much improved upon and i'm
really glad that with the tone with this
that they
weren't confident enough to actually
lead with comedy as a force to the prior
marketing
this already looks like i'm pretty
confident that this is going to be an
improvement over the first
one that we enjoyed but uh this looks
like they really
they really are gonna improve upon it
i'm i'm very i'm
very much excited for this yeah guys
what'd you think of this venom let there
be karna trailer subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell hit
that like button leave your thoughts
down below
last but not least
justin whose name fits in this rhyme
pattern
it's your name so it's your shout out
today
justin hope you're doing well i hope
you're venom fan you're the first name
that popped out to me that i could
possibly fit into eminem's theme song
which we didn't talk about in this video
but i hope eminem does a theme song for
this movie and i hope that he name
checks
you in the song because you're hardcore
you're a gangster and you could take on
venom i think you could so
let's get that hip-hop theme song for
you going i'm probably not gonna write
it because i'm not that good of a
freestyle rapper right now but uh
next shout out it's gonna be a
full-fledged song just you wait buddy
thank you justin for being you let
carnage reek upon our patreon justin